welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Joe head who works for an
agency called Mark James
Mark James are a boutique
multi-discipline the recruitment company
and Joe join them seven months ago as an
associate director to help them build
their technology arm from scratch and
previous to this Joe worked for Austin
Fraser for six years so Joe thank you
for joining me
yeah thank you very much for having me
preciate you excited to have you one
obviously you came to the live event and
November didn't me didn't you yes yeah
I'm really good event yeah enjoyed and
then you don't have to say that I did
I'm not lying get engaged there and
communicate so been looking forward to
this also we've been chatting before and
I think you have someone that's clearly
really passionate about recruitment
which i think is always great to see and
like just soak up which is really cool
so as you know me where I always like to
start on this podcast
how did Joe into the world of
recruitment I'm probably gonna have the
same answer as most people okay which is
fell into it really yeah so I literally
go to uni no good University I worked in
my a-levels came out school I actually
worked in Hugo Boss
yeah just literally needed a job I was
what fresh-faced 18 year old yeah and
then I had no idea that recruitment even
existed probably like a lot of people
didn't really know what it was about
didn't know that there was even a
professional business that you could go
into in that space I've got a call from
my old company office in Fraser as a
training consultant and yeah it's kind
of it really I was like to be fair
actually thought I messed up the
interview really yeah I went to the
final stage interview in a pair of jeans
Wow yeah I saw just like you know what
I'm gonna give it a give it a go why not
why not be quirky yeah I kind of got a
lot of looks in the office really when I
walked for a birdie not a few words you
go boss though like skinny or like
tailored they well they were just like
skinny fit black jeans yeah I want to be
fair I wore like a nice blazer on a show
on top of it so you look
you can look quite smart yeah I look
quite smart but I did actually think I'd
like did the day bring up an interview
they've actually brought up my feedback
for my interview saying look we like to
lobby for it you did well but why did
you wear jeans and I was like ah yeah I
just got the vibe from the office that
yeah I was gonna wear a pair of jeans
yeah I mean the internal recruited oh
come on
yeah yes surely do you know I actually
can't really remember
they must even they should oh yeah yeah
right back just say no you think about
wearing jeans don't ya I know I don't
know what I do but I've got the job yeah
so yeah do you think that if you was to
go if you were to interview or some
friends are now and wear jeans and with
that outfit do you think you would get a
second look because I've been sorted and
Fraser offices yeah I know probably not
I probably sounds at you fine that's
cool
but I think that's what's changed a bit
yeah the back in the day it was like
yeah like you yeah I like that's kind of
what was expected but yeah I'm here to
break the north cool so let's just frame
mark for everyone so join Austin Fraser
there if you don't know awesome Fraser
big global recruitment business and I
think they have a great brand sort of
online from what can see so you join
there and stayed there for six and a bit
six years so real solid still with your
first recruitment job and then obviously
a seven months ago you joined a smaller
boutique agency often leaving Austin
frenzy yeah yo cool so let's first like
really dive into your journey Austin
Fraser so just a frame man so as I said
I've been to Austin and Fred's offices
in red in really impressive
obviously right now if you were to look
at them online you think they're huge
big whatever so what what was it like
when you joined first yeah so we
actually had a completely different
office still in reading we had just one
pretty much one floor how many people
probably like maybe 50 60 so like
compared to what it is now like now
we're talking we're talking 250 300
people yes yes you went through that
yeah like literally saw everything saw
them open up multiple different offices
went with that kind of whole journey
with them kind of watch them grow really
as a business and you know in like to be
fair like I actually can't fall anything
about the business they taught me
everything I knew and I wouldn't be kind
of in the situation although right now
without that that experience so ok so
again sort of just a fun to put on that
so did you saw from what I saw on
LinkedIn you had the typical route of so
training consult and then consult and
then senior consultant and then yeah you
left yeah pretty much they started I was
a trainee yeah I mean like everyone
trainee can saw and it was hard yeah
what was the first license I think it
but I didn't do my first deal for 10
months
between 10 months to do a deal really
yeah you said before so was you in
contract that whole time that you
started did you then flip to perm so I
started off as a contract consultant and
it literally like for me like I was
putting in the hours like I was like
working really putting in the work yeah
yeah basically like putting in the work
like being in the office one night till
like at 11 o'clock at night really like
going through CVS because like my
manager was like if you don't have CVS
for this job tomorrow like you'll get
into bollocky basic really sorry to butt
in but I did may or may not listen to it
but I shared a podcast not too long ago
with a guy called Lloyd him and he
spoken about this and when he ended up
had a really late night he got a hotel
did you get a hotel not quite not
getting the bus home like really late
really really late like mum was like BAM
I'm like what like 18 at this point yeah
my mum was like what you can do it not
working this late not realizing like
Vanna
you got a D so okay so how do you do
contract for so I did contract for I
think yeah II yeah for the whole 10
months and I didn't actually show when
when I first learnt often phrases the
rule was you have to do three pulling
places so for anyone that obviously
doesn't know understand a pull in place
it's kinda like three self-generated
not part by anyone getting the client
herself agree in the terms and doing the
do yourself so it actually took me so
it's really really weird story so um I
was actually took 10 months to get
promoted and I was actually on
performance management I was literally
on the brink of being fired pretty much
because they were like what's going on
like doesn't basically I'm not even
afraid to admit it like I probably was
am I my manager was probably pulling his
hair reason why maybe he's balding like
at the moment but yeah like I was on
performance management like people were
just like you're not why are you not
getting it sort of thing like what was
the situation why are you not like it
typically people can get rude pretty
quickly like they had like a training
and stuff and I just wasn't getting it I
literally just could not get them ahead
around recruitment and couldn't get it
interestingly when I got put on
performance management I did three deals
in the month after in 1 billion in free
putting places and got promoted so why'd
you think Eisen let's talk about that I
think something that I always get
messages about is this overly part of
their career and I think the fact that
you didn't bill will make do any deals
for for 10 months let's definitely talk
a bit about that yeah so like why do you
think that is then I think so I kind of
look on it in reflection now and I think
like for a lot of people that were
really young going into it like yeah I
had no consequences for me not doing a
deal okay so like I was living at home
my mom and sister like paid like okay
money on a salary for someone that's
like you know yeah and has no real no
bills or anything like I didn't have
that kind of like the comp there was no
consequence I mean not doing well so you
know those people in recruitment have
like their Y and their reason for like
mmm wanting to do well whether that be a
family you know house like that kind of
said when he was young as like I was
like you don't have those things in
that's life but he was working hard
while you were hard I think for me I was
just a bit of like self pride like
really you didn't I didn't want to get I
kind of bought into the culture and how
much I enjoyed that place I didn't want
to be that guy that got fired right
felled and I think like actually being
put on performance management and I had
this conversation with my old manager
that actually kinda gives you up there's
a there's a consequence of you if you
don't do well yeah you're gonna get
yeah and that's kind of why I think kind
of spurred me on and I was like oh [ __ ]
there's a consequence I better like yeah
I better do something about this yeah so
what what made you what made you what do
you think looking back now what do you
think made you continuing those two the
first time why didn't you quit yourself
I think I just saw for me like I just
had like I could see other people doing
while I was with like really like I had
a really really like successful manager
people around me doing quite well and I
was like I want some of that like I kind
of immediately got on with a lot of
people there I did want to lose that
kind of like I did want to lose that
like you know even now I'm friends with
like a lot of people that still there
that I've known my whole career yeah but
I think like for me I didn't want to
kind of walk away from that and I didn't
want to quit and did not want to give up
I was like I'm gonna keep doing it I'm
gonna keep doing it yeah so that was a
big factor
yeah massively I think massively like
there was that like just just didn't
want to fail what was I saying to you
lots of things probably some things I
can't repeat yeah yeah on this podcast
like you're on your way out yeah pretty
much they were like like every review
that's having like daily review really
look like kpi's why they not like where
they are like properly like you know
like going in on me for a lot of things
and like whether that be like how many
managers you added and how many lives
you'll get in not what's going on kind
of thing yeah and I think literally
going on that performance management
probably the best thing that's ever
happened to me you could really think
I'd have gone back into recruitment if I
had been really fired but yeah like I
think that it was that kind of
consequence and I think like having a
reason why like you do the things you do
and like my Y as bad as it sounds at the
time with my wife a smash and work at
that time in that kind of one month when
I got promoted was because I didn't want
to get fired yeah that was kind of it
but a lot of people have different ways
of like yeah you know have you got kids
and that period made your type of
interest did you ask for help
[Music]
probably but I think a lot of what I was
quite like we had a training program and
it was like like not like now is this is
really really good training pronoun back
in the day it was like six weeks at a
room yeah you learn some stuff for a
3-man yeah like classroom and I think
for a lot of people that doesn't
necessarily work that well like for me I
couldn't learn like that yeah you
there was probably at times when I was
like I'd really really need some help
but then other times you were just like
I think you would just think that and
this were like I guess as I've got older
in my recruitment career like you learn
to work smarter and not harder yeah like
I could put all the hours in in the day
but think Kendal's out of it didn't do
the right things didn't get the things I
needed to be successful it's just like
yeah I've added 20 managers in one day
what's come up a lot recently is because
it's just interesting there you send
that people around you obviously giving
you a bit of banter and you obviously
have to do some internal selling the
look this is something I want to do I'm
really grafting even though my copias
might not be quite there so you always
have to do some internal selling to keep
your job clearly yeah I'm just
interested because I think what a lot of
people underestimate and I definitely
didn't utilize this because when you are
surrounded by people that are doing well
and these sorts of things it can be
quite daunting or intimidating you can't
be quite intimidated by the top billing
or intimidate so I think what's come up
a lot which is why I ask that question
is don't underestimate home and how
people are willing to help so just so
clear from what you said I think I make
an assumption that you probably didn't
ask for that much do you know what's
really interesting I think that's kind
of like again I I don't know because
I've only worked for what to recruit is
now but I think like when you're like in
that situation I don't I think it can be
quite daunting you can be quite sort of
like put off by asking someone for help
really well but I think that kind of is
slowly changed like I'm massively in it
yeah yeah in the industry as a whole
that is kind of the whole mindset of
recruitment now and even at the event
you know a lot of people were saying
this now it sounds weird to say but it's
now considered a bit more of a
professional business to kind of go into
so I think when you're young and you're
like oh you know you just think that oh
we aren't going to do all this hard work
and it's gonna happen like actually
looking back though we would have asked
for help to run that off then like no
more you know now like what what would
you have done differently to ensure that
it didn't take ten months for you to do
it do a pull in place listen to my
manager probably more really know you
sort of feel like you did you have that
sort of mentality you as young they're
right yeah yeah I think yeah I think
like I guess like how do I know let's
say you know
knew everything I knew now about
recruitment I think had I had just done
the basics of what recruitment is and
had I just stuck to that daily and not
got so kind of worried and panicky and
working till like you know late night so
like I said like 11:00 11:30 at night
how died actually just taken the whole
like you know work smarter not harder
hmm I'd probably would have been yeah
got promoted a lot but long before yeah
yeah but actually to be fair I'm pretty
grateful for that kind of journey I'm
really grateful for actually failing and
really not doing so well and then kind
of actually like learning from that
massively yeah okay and so then did you
first couple of deals after the
performance management yeah okay cool so
you won then what you ended up with
obviously in a contract world do you end
up having a few runners and yeah I think
I've got two I saw wait yep so I got
promoted to a recruitment consultant
yeah then I ended up getting to about I
think of an about three grand weekly GP
sole it really like nothing really like
considering like some of the people that
were that yeah I think I did like eighty
thousand yeah like what in that first
year no I think that was kind of a year
from getting promoted like so like
usually you know yeah I think it was
about like 80,000 like something like
that and then I I couldn't I don't know
for me the kind of journey that I went
on was like I could not on the contract
market get like over three grand I think
really was like I even think you
struggle so much because I'm regretted
saying yeah you know I'm I thought I
couldn't put my I got scum bit my finger
on it necessarily about the main reasons
but I think like maybe the way I am is
like an individual like I'm like there
were a lot contract recruiters that are
really good that very very like salesy
like back in the day were like on it
gosh but Bosh straight on it bang bang
bang bang bang like they knew candidates
they were cool market where they like
doing in deals constantly and I was kind
of like got to a point where like I was
had like three grand but I'd like 1500
quid to ever finishes it in like a month
so I was like oh [ __ ] about to go bad so
um but luckily like really interestingly
like I got switched over to perm why'd
you guys did you ask for that kind of
ask for it but also
it was an opportunity that came up like
my manager was like there's actually
could be some really good there's some
good things that you'll do it in as an
person you know you build a lot of
rapport with people or like on ya a bit
more suitable perm like very very luck
personable and you can build
relationships with people which in perm
is you actually need that quite a lot
especially when you're ultimately making
like life-changing decisions for people
yeah yeah so yeah I switched over to
perm kind of business decision slash
kind of I wanted to keep my job so yes I
switched over to perm and actually
interestingly like my first month on
perm I did like 20 odd grand well for
business like my first month not like
that I just bailed the deal about 20
grand I was like okay this is probably
gonna be my route from now so then ever
since then you done poem which is war
like for not business yeah literally yes
ever since then been being a perm accrue
everything but then like I think
actually like the contract mentality
that I've got like has really helped me
as well because having that mentality of
like you know as a contractor something
you get a contract job on you need to
know Seavey's like straight away know so
that the urgency is that really help me
in the perm kind of side of things like
when weird like selling to Canada or a
client like there's like an element as
always that urgency quicker and that
people we sell perm takes a lot longer
but like it doesn't have to if you can
make it like actually you can make
things turn around quite quickly
yeah or you can just you can apply that
same urgency to everything that's
involved in the plan real critical
literally everything you can just apply
that same urgency and yes a mentality of
like actually if a poem job comes up I
still know the three best guys to go to
like I still know those candidates I see
you at CES so you're grateful that that
ended up being your route because it's
obviously a book quit chewy yeah yeah
massively and that's what like always
what kind of said to me was actually
that urgency that you got to get stuff
done and you know the fact that I had
that kind of mentality ver when we had a
poem job I already knew three good
candidates because if that's what you
needed to do on the contract side
contract days you like have to know the
candidates I was another agent shoot
fill the job so I think that's really
not massively helped me kind of step I'm
game up so it's the biggest learning
than in those first two years my what
we're saying cuz clearly struggled yeah
massively because there'll be Peter
they'll be contrary agrees listening
that might be going through that run
yeah I think like the biggest kind of
learn for me was like again and I still
do this today right is sticking to the
basics of what recruitment is
recruitment is not hard like it is not
necessarily a hard thing to do but you
people can make it really really
difficult because they get kind of
really worked I mean it's interesting to
say that sorry to butt in but I had to
record an episode with a guy couldn't
comment and he he hates people saying
that recruitment hard today
really but I know I'll get I'll get the
context of what you're saying also
there's context is important that but
all he means by that is he just fine it
he finds that because he has dedicated
over a decade of his life to been the
best recruiter he can be yeah for
someone to sort of just discount what he
does as easy to do he doesn't like that
but I get what you're saying as in like
getting back to the basics and not over
complicate yeah the more likely it's not
okay yet recruitment it's not an easy
job to do but the fundamentals of what
you're what like if you actually take it
back to its bare bones of what
recruitment is we talk to candidates we
find those good candidates for jobs yeah
and actually like people can really over
complicate that quite a lot and I think
if you like talking to like your manager
or someone I think it's important to not
over complicate that like if you're okay
fair enough if you haven't got any jobs
on okay what's the first thing you do go
and top some candidates like learn and I
think even if you're brand new to
recruitment the first thing you do is
you talk to people together get to
understand you would have got back to
base it yeah definitely did you what was
you overcomplicating then I think I was
probably just over complicating a lot of
the times especially in technology
recruit me you can kind of over
complicate a lot of what the job
actually is in terms of like you know
you take a really good jobs back and I
think because you want to find the
perfect candidate for the job and
especially in contract recruitment
that's not you know contract recruitment
is Right three four good really good
contract CVS
send him to the client I think for me I
was kind of like oh no I'm not too sure
of this person's and I mean I had it at
times I'd be like I remember one deal
like a core member exactly when but it
was like you'd speak to the guy go nah
he's not quite right for the job and
then he goes and gets the job yeah kind
of like that's where you get better at
yeah and that's what you get better at
right and I think so if I was to locate
that makes sense
yes I think if you would like
don't kind of over complicate life
you're brand-new to contract recruitment
don't overcomplicate if you take a good
job sake from someone don't lie think
this guy's not right because he hasn't
got ask her manager but I think I think
what I learn as a permanent career which
you get better at is never done it don't
ever assume yeah massively right that's
like that yeah it's so true and I think
that that's put I love the way that you
just articulate that I think that's
really true I think a lot of people can
benefit from now and I think you're
quite prone to that early on yes I
remember I remember especially early on
when you're you're not as confident as
you would be two years down the line
freeze on like getting on the phone
being proactive like for me I always
remember when like I wasn't as confident
on the phone and I'd look at CVS and lie
because I want cuz you just wired to
pick the easiest option in your life
right yeah I was looking for reasons not
to call that person yeah yeah yeah I
mean I mean I remember yeah sitting
there like when you're brand new to a
group that's it in there and by the time
you're worried about what you're gonna
say yeah I might not even pick up the
phone like you're there you're there
like worrying about it like oh my god
what's this guy gonna think like and
even things like things like asking for
someone to go oh by the way who did you
work for in your last job people are so
like oh my god I can't a suck yeah yeah
yeah essentially that you don't know
that that guy might just turn around
what was this guy he's so great advice
don't overcomplicate don't don't assume
and if you do assume and someone gets a
job that you spoke some about not free
that's the keeping which we'll get onto
around resilience right is it's about
learning from the mistakes and and don't
do them again yeah so so I think that
yeah I love that you said on that that's
great great advice
so transitioned into a pond recruiter so
did you stay in the same similar market
or do you change market or yes so I
actually stayed in the complete say
market which was actually quite good
I'd already learnt all the technologies
and yeah kind of kind of knew already
that that market how to kind of work it
right yeah massively so first year as a
plumber career then have been your third
year yeah the recruiting I was actually
did 20 or so grand in the first month
yeah
20 grand in the first month and then I
think I actually ended up I did oh I
didn't actually like not too bad
considering I kind of changed a perm I
think I ended up doing about 150 much
better than three grand a week me yeah
exactly yeah tell me about it say yes I
kind of yeah like God got to that level
I've just started enjoying my work like
really like massively like I started to
kind of it's weird like such a old
school saying but the penny dropped and
it kind of did like the penny drops when
you're doing it and then suddenly like
you learn from your mistakes of like
what I wasn't doing before and then I
was like asking people and then I
started to get you know everyone like
when you start doing deals you get more
confidence you get that kind of aura of
confidence to go and cool people and you
start asking the right questions and
using that confidence to kind of kind of
just like get my career like back on
track sort of thing yeah and so just to
help me out so from that point did you
then just stay as a billa or did you
manage people so that point I just
stayed as a biller so I
yeah when went through like wanted to
get my senior consultant like that was
like a really big thing for me um what
was that how was that Matt how did you
get senior so we had to do there's a
hundred and twenty grams worth has 160
grams worth of starters in a six-month
period you had to have everyone start
when they started as long as it was in a
six-month period yeah and then you'd be
promoted so knew that was your next lot
real girl yeah that's my next real goal
and actually I think the one thing for
me that I guess kind of really helped me
get there and something I wanted to say
was kind of having a bit of self-worth
and that was something that my mindset
really changed like in my like one offs
I don't plan recruitment I did you know
I did have like an okay yeah and then
like I started kind of valuing a lot
more about what I was doing because I
could see like how much what I was
putting in and I was like saying I was
like start telling clients I was like
this is how much work I put in like and
then I was increasing my percentages and
then I was getting like more like
exclusivity on jobs or you know
upgrading those jobs of interview starts
and I think what for me that was the
biggest thing I changed up in my mindset
was just valuing my work how did you
change that
um like what did anything happen or like
how long how did you change it I think
it just sort of became like I think that
probably was an element of like the
confidence of like doing a few yo-yos
and kind of going along and then I was
just like you know what I'm working so
hard but I'm getting clients that maybe
like you know like messing me about or
like not doing the right things for me
and I'm like actually why are they not
doing the right things to me I'm doing
all this hard work for EM so I started
like telling clients about how hard I
was working and I started saying to
clients look if you don't want that kind
of service then that's not kind of like
we don't work with you and I think that
comes out like that kind of self like
value what you do as an individual as
recruiters we work hard that we work
hard we put the hours in yeah but a lot
of people don't tell their clients that
yeah thanks dr. Lee I never understood
that and I've like tell your clients how
hard you work so they get an insight
into your job yeah they've got probably
no problem telling you how busy their
day is or yeah how hard they're working
or the hours they're put yeah and so
tell it to them as well I think that's
such a great insight I think there's two
things and there is as you said I think
that it comes with actually the
realization of helping a lot of people
working with businesses and making
placements and all that and actually
recognize it and how much of an impact
you have on their business and how
valuable it is what you're doing so yeah
so I think there's two things in there
one yeah like when you really realize
like how like really believe in so I
think for me what changed for me when I
was in marketing so I did two and a half
years and I would say 18 months in I
sort of had that moment yeah and when
you like really believe that when you're
not funds that kind of that kind that
they are you are the best person that
they should be speaking to you that's
when [ __ ] changes yeah and you don't
truly believe that and because that just
comes out of everything that you
communicate stuff of that so that's
great and then the other thing actually
totally right is educating your clients
and candidates on what you do on a daily
basis because you'd be surprised that
again people assume that these people
know what you're doing how you work yeah
it's really interesting because one of
the sort of early videos that I made and
I was in recruitment is like the third
video it was all about and just
educating people what we do so the video
is pretty pretty much like so just let
you all know that when we
you take on a job we don't post a job on
read and then put our feet up yeah yeah
but lots of people you'd be so surprised
even in even now people that are like
hiring managers or people that are like
even like some like HR people probably
just like oh you just put an out job
advert up and you hope that someone
applies for it well actually if you work
in a really really kind of niche
technology market or a niche market or
any market for that matter we're out
there we're going to like communities
meetups or meeting people we are talking
to like like maybe 10 15 20 people a day
to get our networks up and I think like
a lot of people don't realize how much
time you put in like what happens if we
haven't when we as recruiters don't have
any jobs on we're still talking to
candidates we're still there building
that Network so that when clients like
whoever we're talking to you need their
job field
we've got people straightaway and I
think people do like a lot of people
just think we pluck candidates from the
air and yeah we're just out there yeah
do those candidates let's make some
money how did how did you communicate
that and getting better at that help
help you like how much would impact that
they have then so you mentioned around
fees and stuff for that yeah massively
like it just it took I'd say like if
you're when you do it you kind of like I
think there is an element of being
really brave like you have to be brave
what sort of things did you say then so
articulate like what's a client yes like
what did you start to it because I'm
sure you end up just getting a bit of a
spill don't you so like what did you
just kind of say you would basically
walk through clients for the steps of
like what you do on a daily basis and
like there's gonna be quite a few people
listening that might have good pictures
like this or people that maybe don't
have pitches but for me I was always
like right look these are the reasons
why I am the best recruit I've recruited
in this market I've only ever done this
technology like I'm only able work in
this one market I talk to people day in
day out I recruits if eclis in London
and I work with clients that like that
basically have the same kind of setup as
you guys the same technology they're
competitors of yours and I know them and
I can go and like either headhunt people
for you or I can go and do like you know
really really good kind of like
acquisition kind of projects for you and
just telling me when like the thing
around like meetups and communities and
you know we I did that quite a bit and
going to meet people and just having a
bit more of like that real confidence to
say exactly what you do
there are some like I say we said it
like there's people that have no clue
what you do in recruitment they just
think that you find people and that's it
yeah and that helps you raise your fees
yeah because you then start negotiating
a lot more and then like you know even
if you're like like say that one that's
a 1% on every deal you've done over the
course of a year it makes a huge
difference like massive massive
difference to your billions and I think
like as mutt and walk away from business
that don't want to work with you if
they're like oh we only work at 15% and
we work with six agencies just say look
cool really sorry like I don't want to
give you the service I've currently
provided because I don't give a 15%
service I give a 25% service a lot of
power and yeah it's a lot parent and
people have actually like sometimes
people are like oh actually I kind of
want to know what that 25% yes is life
don't wanna like you know what am I not
getting from yes I think yeah I think
it's really important to like just be
confident I know that takes time though
it's always it's really like applaud
anyone that like is new to recruitment
that can walk away from business and I
think that's a really brave thing to do
because when you're new you want these
jobs on actually if you're like there
the first you know you're a new recruit
and you're going you know what I'm gonna
really have some self-worth and value
myself I don't want to work that 15%
laughing that's great mate so I think I
think yeah so I think if you if you're
like if you really start believing in
the value and service that you bring to
your clients candidates and really start
articulating educating more not over
over communicating what you actually do
on a daily basis how hard you work
yeah yeah that will go a long way
massively yeah 100% like just start
explaining let's start telling not even
across the industry recruiting that's
not telling me what we do and why we
work as hard as we do yeah it's not just
because we're not like sowing our feet
up and just hoping the 20 grand deal was
comfortable we actually work for it okay
cool
so let's just talk a bit about so
obviously home recruits did about a
hundred fifty count your first year so
obviously clima really motivated to get
that senior title which involved hundred
twenty hundred fifty k of new businesses
yet six months yeah so how did you do
performance wise like billings wise up
until the point you left them so I think
the
I think the last year I did like I was
nobody nowhere near like an amazing
recruiter like I worked with some people
that were like really really good good
perm recruiters that we're doing like
five six hundred I think I got just
under three hundred what is your best
[ __ ] yeah I think is like 280 that's
good man so like yeah like like that's
what I think the wind is just to help me
out because let's break this down when
did you get to when was the year that
you hit it was actually last 2001 Fraser
what pretty much so your last year
pretty much my biggest year yeah which
is I guess kind of like like interesting
in a sense can people be like well why
did you leave why did you leave well
we'll go into that but I guess what I'd
love to just for you to share and it's
articulate and talk a bit about and I'm
sure some of it is what we were just
talking about but again real common
thing that I get is hisham for the last
three month three years up here 150
count it okay like how the [ __ ] do I
break this 200k mark or obviously you
came close hitting friends okay more
yeah so I think there's an interesting
factor there we were talking about
before we started this is one you were
surrounded by people that were doing
bigger than numbers than you anyway yeah
it has an impact right so I guess yeah
what's your sort of perspective and
force on how you manage to sort of level
up your Billings and continue to
increase those so I think definitely
like we're just touching it like the
self-worth of your business was like
it's so important that really helped me
but again like we mentioned it earlier
like going back to the basics of what
recruitment is like no matter how good
you kind of like are and even if you're
like an amazing billet like just if you
still do the basics of like okay well
we're still you still need to do like BD
and you need to like add new contacts
and new managers into the system and you
still need to kind of take it back like
to what is is a successful like method
of like and obviously there'll be done
different recruitment companies out
there like AF had their own kind of I
guess kind of success measures in terms
of like the KPIs and the figures but I
think you kind of have to still do kpi's
like what more were there so I think it
was 10 it's a week it was called ten
five to ten fold so it was that ten ten
interviews
five five jobs to come remember it now
to something like this a week yes it's
like a weekly basis of like what your
kpi's would be mmm and I'd say to anyone
that like because one thing I see in
recruitment a lot is like oh we're not
KPI driven we're not KPI driven but I'm
like kind of like don't necessarily
understand that quite fully cuz actually
kpi's are the fundamentals of most sales
job yeah you need to understand more new
student daily basis to get you to yeah
point A and point B exactly so like I
don't think like just doing the KPIs and
don't be afraid to do them I think
people should be afraid to talk about
KPIs and o night as lows economies at
all we're not KPI driven and we're not
gonna stop well you kind of have to be
like in sales I mean people shouldn't be
afraid or be scared to kind of mention
about KPIs and doing again just a quick
one on AB let's definitely stay down
this have a few things so just one of
the questions that I got from someone
that was on this actually I wrote down
on here was so they said one thing I'll
be interested in would be maybe a bit of
chat specifically around big recruitment
fairs but she was in and how an
overemphasis on kpi's can sometimes
prove counterintuitive
it's um is something I found problematic
and my short in my short time in the
bigger firm whereby I actively had to
stop chasing leads because I had only
done 45 minutes business development but
like what your thoughts on that like
because you work for a bigger firm yeah
I think I think yeah massively kpi's can
be detrimental like to business like
them absolutely no doubt if you've got a
manager that's breathing down your neck
and he's done your 10 mate yeah you're
massively that is going to be an effect
on like your workload also like mentally
that's gonna really affect you yeah and
you're you're gonna be like getting down
about it like if you haven't done it I
think there's like as a as a leader and
as a manager at any business you have to
be really kind of like careful in the
way you talk about it but it has to be
fun you have to talk about because most
every single company like recruitment
company sales company they're
results-driven you we don't you know
unless you're kind of lucky you don't
have like we do most businesses don't
have a million different clients that
just come into
jobs like a non-stop right so I think if
you do it in a way that is which is kind
of it's inspiring to someone they can
see the benefit of why they're doing it
yeah then they're gonna do it so
something that like I've trying to do at
the moment is actually a be a bit more
like okay well I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
show you how to do it you know how what
works well why it works well you're not
just telling you to do it yeah because
then you're not actually seeing the
result yeah so I think if you're like
actually on that journey with someone
especially if they're new as a leader as
a leader or as a manager you should be
kind of demonstrating how it's done yeah
and I think that and I and so I guess if
you're so if you're listening right now
in your life [ __ ] are my manager
keeps banging on me about getting ten
bit doing ten business the getting speed
to ten decision-makers before ten
o'clock or whatever and you're getting
bogged down by it like I think it's fair
to say then you need to communicate
yeah only yeah like one one last
yourself a question do you know why
you've got to do that yeah cuz that's
what you're saying them yeah yeah
actually see the value in why they've
set these KPIs or indicate indicators us
too so one tech step back from it
instead of just pointing a finger at
your manager getting down getting you
down like why do you know why why
they've told you to do this and then to
if you think it is a bit too much or
unrealistic or it's affecting other
things when you're making poor decisions
like 45 minutes business development or
whatever that's yeah that's not a good
thing yeah community communicate
internally yeah I mean definitely like
most people the reason people don't do
things is if they don't see value in it
yeah I think like there has to be like
you know what why why is that person why
does that person need to add ten
managers or do more business development
per se and I think like if you're
educated around it and I think that's
one of the biggest things like coming
new to a crewman I think if you've got a
really really good kind of someone
that's like educating you around kind of
the principles of what recruitment is
and how we do it and the kind of
fundamentals of what makeup recruitment
yeah I think then you're going to learn
a lot more
I think it's there's obviously certain
businesses may be out there that are
like you know their managers just might
do this and if you don't do this
well you're going to be what is that
[ __ ] that person isn't going to know
Lu what any of that really means so they
I think they just need to kind of like
you need to be able to demonstrate that
person the benefit and doing it and that
might take someone just to go like get
on the phone and talk to a candid or
talk to a manager and show them a little
bit of how it's done you know and give
them that kind of like you know what
this guy's actually like this guy's
inspiring me I see value in doing it I
want to be about that person nice so
what I'd like to talk a bit about
because I think this is also part of
what you're indicating to so a real
common thing that a lot of people ask me
about well as well is sort of what your
day looks like and management time
management stuff like that so I think
obviously when I ask you around getting
your Billings to those sorts of figures
from 150k and continuing to improve
those and you was talking about getting
back making sure you're doing the basics
right you're hitting you know what you
need to do to the kpp stuff so I guess
what I'd like to think about and share
is what how what was different in your
day if it was the you would that you had
in your day or how you structured your
day when he was billing 150k compared to
280k because I'm sure there's some
non-negotiables that you sort of start
to evolve I have like what does that
look like yeah so I think like in terms
like Dave structure I think I was like
to anyone like you've got to be really
really kind of like rigid with it like
you got to stick to it because so many
times I mean I've done it I'm sure like
you did people do it where they say oh
I'm going to do this and then they don't
and then it's like oh why don't you do
that ah I had some other things to do
and I think it's like I just find it
like when you've struct your day right
go to the go to the top of the listing
right what's the most important thing
look at like always like look at my jobs
so I write in the morning let's have a
look let's see what jobs are working
they say spray tan your day there
because I'm sure this is what got better
compared to you yeah early on break
break down your day and be really kind
of like and stick to it as well and
actually do it like if you're gonna
write you're gonna say right I know that
I need to book in five interviews today
or I need to find five candidates to
send to that job because the clients
really need TV then kind of like hold
yourself accountable for it
you know and if you haven't done it by
the time the day shot like then stay and
do it and there's nothing wrong with
that like yeah it's not like we're not
saying to people like I'll work you know
they're incredible hours but if you said
to yourself really really need to do
this today I need to get this done yeah
cuz I know this is going to help me
then kind of hold yourself accountable
I'm actually gonna get this done so for
me like I always now like my day is kind
of structured like right take a look at
the jobs we got on let's understand like
who our best clients are who's coming
back to us on that CV feedback yes of
prioritizing relationships that yeah
okay yeah massively like prioritize your
like relationships over people that
aren't giving you that kind of service
yes again that comes down to kind of
value if that's the first thing you're
done yeah so like looking at looking at
the jobs going right these are the kind
of best ones I'm gonna kind of work on
these if you haven't twigs that client
in awhile or you know you've not heard
back from gimmick or there's nothing
wrong like often I see it like I don't
want to call the client so I don't want
to know them or you know I only sent CV
yesterday I thought well actually
they've asked you to send the TVs and
all you all you're doing is kind of
chasing you know feedback because that
candidate has chased you or that kandan
wants to know if he's successful job so
I think like if you do it again in like
a real constructive way in a way in
which that doesn't annoy the client it's
fine to call those people yeah so it
always like trying to like at the moment
like having a big push on you know the
clients we have got is kind of nurturing
them a little bit yeah and like actually
like let's see where we can no less ask
for some feedback like how are we do it
like how are we performing against your
other agencies how are we how are you
finding working with us as I think
feedbacks are really really important so
I know we kind of take a bit of a
tangent that's a day plan but I make
sense so and so so it sounds like then
is what you got better is recognizing
and understanding like what were your
hot jobs or the jobs it should be
spending time on and that and then would
that fuel the rest of your day then like
so you'd kind of like fuel the rest of
your day of course there's always gonna
be things like so I will always see
things like you know chasing the leads
down like oh well who's interviewing
where who's hiring at the moment and
let's kind of have those days but and
you'd always kind of dedicate some time
to those really kind of hot the hot
stuff basically that's like out there
like they're recruiting I heard that
they were recruiting yesterday yeah like
yesterday evening I spoke to someone and
how they were recruiting so I want to go
straight along trying yeah I know I'm
trying to hunt that down so did you do
you block out time in your diary or not
yeah actually so at the moment we do
like sales days so that everyone's kind
of in it together so everyone's involved
and then
every Wednesday like we kind of have a
bit of a sales push because it's kind of
bringing everyone as a team together
doing it I think it creates a really
good buzz in the office I think it's
quite sort of so you didn't Bedi all day
yeah literally just like is it yeah yeah
you know of course there are like
exceptions no like you know if you've
got stuff to sort out yeah of course but
we're we're sort of like trying to do
something at the moment works just like
bringing everyone together I'm a bit of
a push together to get this done of
course there's gonna be times when you
need to do BD another day yeah and I
think that's more of like a
self-awareness thing it's like if you
would get to like a Thursday and you're
like have done any bit equals maybe I
you know ask your manager like where can
I bring the list up what can i yeah what
can I do like what can I do differently
or I need I need some help kind of
thinking of the people - cool yeah okay
but yeah definitely that the whole thing
about kind of like prioritizing your
workload about what's most important so
like if you haven't got any jobs cool
where are those jobs gonna come from
okay and just having like a little sit
now and a little plan of action for the
day like right
okay I'm haven't got any jobs I know
that all those people to recruit and I'm
gonna really really try and get those
jobs on yeah the next base the next best
thing after if they can't get a job on
is trying a meeting yeah it's just like
just like breaking it down little by
little to kind of and don't like we
always say I always say celebrate the
small wins okay like there's no if you
didn't get a job on but you've got a
meeting that's amazing like don't don't
kind of beat yourself up because you
didn't get the job on but you've got a
meeting with a new client celebrate that
like I mean no that's amazing work
anyway yeah so I guess just to run that
off mate I'm looking at this question
that someone sent me is pretty much like
it's pretty much what I sort of watches
so just to run off is like it's this
person so they're like to always hear
the daily routines of a real creature in
their first year versus their year four
or five plus what daily must do has
changed it's like just to run that off
what would you say the sort of daily
must do that's changed that when he was
you year one recruitment career I think
year one was like what changed like for
me like a year one was like massively
beady focus and being really kind of
like right that was that was kind of the
goal be really focused on that and
set yourself kind of really simple
targets to kind of hit of like BD yeah
and trying to you know get in front of
those clients and I think as you kind of
go on in your career things slowly check
the slightly change because you're
you've got more clients which you kind
of like as you kind of get older in your
career you get you have those clients
you have those jobs to work and I think
again that comes down to like the I
guess the routine and what I do now is
be kind of really specific with those
jobs and nurture those relationships
because too many times and recruitment
you know I'm sure there's other people
out there they're like you could have
had a really good relationship yeah and
for whatever reason it was neglected it
wasn't worked out you never got the you
know what you thinking about a new
client new client new client yeah
exactly exactly so I think it's really
important to lie yeah definitely in in
like year one if you're like brand new
to recruit them structs your day like
talk to your manager about like what's
gonna work for you and that could be
different things for different market
you know like that could be different
areas to work on but definitely just
kind of structure it like BD every day
make sure that you're like immersing
yourself in the market make sure you're
talking to enough can that's every day
as well yeah I think it's really
important when you're brand new to
recruitment you have no idea what the
markets like yeah I definitely like just
talked to people like and don't be
afraid that you're maybe like not as
technical as they are like the person
the end of the phone knows you're not
technical yeah in IT recruitment yeah
yeah no I think okay cool and then I
think I think a really key part of that
which I've definitely been victim of and
have done this light I think you
certainly start out by saying I make
sure you stick to it
I think that that's really important
it's like if you do decide going into
next week that this is how you're going
to structure a week or this we're going
to focus on a daily basis then like give
yourself a sort of rung the do this for
four weeks and see sort of what the
returns on actually not really commit to
it from rather than doing it for
danghang are that'll [ __ ] or whatever
yeah if you didn't get the results of
like the first day like okay cool but
don't let that get yourself down for the
rest of the week yeah at least stick to
it and I think like there's a lot of
time and I've been guilty of it you say
you're gonna do it but then you don't
and it's just like being like like being
accountable for it and holding yourself
accountable and knowing that it's no it
sounds kind of harsh but knowing that if
you don't do it it's no one else's fault
yeah and it's kind of your fault if you
haven't achieved that and you
but they're being accountable yeah yeah
definitely right yeah a hundred hundred
them so let's segue into the sort of
what we've been up to in the last sort
of seven months because you've you've
now sort of immersed yourself into a
completely different environment yeah
use part of a global recruitment
business loatheb surrounded by loads of
people loads of infrastructure and that
light absolutely beneficial and now
you're in a business of how big so
there's nine of us nine yeah and that
was the sort of environment I have found
myself in might say yeah I guess firstly
why don't we just talk a bit about
because just to let everyone know so
like you've gone there and you've stuck
your used in the last seven months
you've had to start a market that's new
to you yeah and new to the recruitment
business
yeah from scratch from scratch so we're
going to talk about that but firstly
what I love you just to share in terms
of the last sort of seven months is and
this was sort of one of the questions
that someone shared with me is sort of
what of what would you say are the
benefits of starting your career with a
large recruitment business or grow
increment business to versus a smaller
one because you've experienced both now
yeah like what yeah well have you got to
share around that and the things that
you picked up on that's different so I
think definitely the benefits of working
for a larger business you are surrounded
by people that can give you help that
people want you to be the best you are
than the best you can you're surrounded
by like really really successful people
a lot of people and everyone's kind of
going in the same direction and that
really motivates you and you learn so
much like and they're big companies like
the one I work for Aston phrase a lot of
great training programs you learn so so
much and I can't I join you we can't
take away and can't say anything bad
about that because they taught me
everything I know about recruitment and
that's very difficult when you're
different to coming into a small
business that maybe don't have that
infrastructure yeah they don't have
those training and development programs
and it can be and is it has been it's
been challenging but kind of fun at the
same time but yeah I definitely say like
the
the training aspect of life goes bigger
really really help like massively and
what have been the positives for you so
far that you've sort of experienced in
the last seven months been in a
nine-person business um I think what's
been really good not actually like I'm
and the directors of the business have
been really receptive to like how how
often phrase we've done work yeah and
they've actually asked me a lot of
questions like oh well what are we doing
well what can we be doing better like
we've kind of hired you to kind of guide
us on that and I think what's Rob really
enjoyed is kind of having a bit of a
voice to be able to kind of change
things and actually like oh I notice
that you guys are doing this maybe we
should try this yeah you know that as a
smaller business the guys of like
listened to things about like the
systems that were you you know the the
job boards that we're now using and I
think that's been really refreshing to
have that kind of people that listen to
you and go and actually yeah we and then
seeing benefits from it as well yeah and
actually this is so much better like you
know we had like an old system called
fire fish which was you know it was
pretty awful if I'm you know sausage
yeah sorry fire fish but then we went to
born right and bullhorn is like you
can't fault it yeah okay no I love that
and I put my own experience in that
that's been that was the biggest value
that I got as well actually having an
opinion that was listened to and then
actually seeing the sort of person who
works you absolutely sucks off for
listen to you implement it and and like
seeing the impacts of that I think
that's really cool yeah yeah definitely
so let's just talk about what the hell
you'd be nuts in the last seven months
because I think again something that's
really popular that people ask me about
is business development and all these
sorts of things right so you've gone
into a niche that you never recruit in
before yeah you joined the nine person
business right like you've got your
comfort zone here yes yes to most people
out we've got door yeah so for me let's
just break down the last seven months
before we finish this episode like like
what what was the game plan like how so
a few things one what was a game plan to
get clients to like how did you plan to
differentiate yourself right like let's
start there like what was a game plan
mate
the game plan was doing do sock guess
what I talked about what I learned from
AF which was get your name out there
start talking to candidates I literally
went in never recruited for this kind of
business practices I cannot like yeah
and there was nothing like literally and
zero no there was real and alas no one
around you was doing the marketing
leverage or no no no it's completely
from scratch it's like absolutely yeah
brand new there wasn't a single
candidate on the database so so the
first thing like I literally did was
just start talking to candidates the
first thing I just I had no idea about
technology and I wasn't in my experience
like I'm not afraid to ask people like
what things mean but if you're brand new
to a technology you have no idea what
you're talking about and talk to counter
and ask them and yeah it's quickly sorry
just because it's like just in my head
like how did you identify the niches
quickly but and the technology just out
of interest like how what how and why
did you pick the because it's
cybersecurity
yes I'm why did you pick that um so I
actually so I actually spoke to I was
actually like an event with someone a
technology event and someone mentioned
about it and I started to kind of look
into a bit more and I sort of saw this
niche and I was I hang on a minute this
is pretty big and I started seeing
things on like the news okay like I mean
most recent one for instance being
Travelex on yeah there was yeah there
was actually one that happened a company
called musk in in Maidenhead that big
shipping company okay and I read an
article on that about how they were like
cyber criminals were basically hacked
into their system yeah and the the CEO
of the business walked in and all on the
black screens yeah he could just see
someone controlling the computers yeah
and it just kind of like sparked from
there so I started taking a bit of an
interest into it and I read in a book
about it and I just kind of found it
really really interesting okay and for
me one thing about like recruiting in
technology if you don't find it
interesting you're Pro not that you're
won't be good at it but if you don't
you'll find it difficult cuz if you
don't find it actually some of that you
really kind of enjoy ya then
kind of like and when I have
conversations with people they're a bit
more like actually this guy's I actually
kind of am enjoying talking about and
like to learn about it okay um so I just
kind of like any kind of like spiraled
out of control
Venna oh actually this is this is really
interesting so for me like if some
advice to anyone starting a brand new
tech market it kind of maybe sit down
with your manager and find out what's
kind of new what's what's interesting to
you as a person because when you start
finding things more interesting you then
can have conversations with people that
aren't about recruitment they're about
the technology like what's the latest
news out there at the moment
yeah and people kind of buy into a lot
more and they think they kind of know
you're a bit more credible yeah so I
just started here I started literally
like reading books on it okay and just
kind of really got into it really and
then I was talking to candidates about
it and all these candidates were really
passionate about it and kind of saying
how its massive and it's gonna be really
big and it's only gonna get bigger yeah
and I think that's a big part just the
punch line there just make it clear love
what you said their self-discovery
really gone out there on your own to
read about these things but then clearly
a big factor of you deciding know what
this is the market and vertical that I'm
gonna build out is that you recognize it
it's gonna be a growing yesterday that's
the key right this is important but you
could find something you're passionate
about but there's no [ __ ] money in it
isn't that point well yeah okay yeah
definitely I think like you can actually
do that as a recruiter you can kind of
sit down and do your own research just
you know go on log on Google go writing
tech trends for yeah 2020 or you know
and beyond and kind of see like what
people are recruiting for go on to like
IT jobs watch and I'll tell you like
what the average salaries are for tech
jobs in anisha's and you know within
certain areas like you know
cybersecurity for instance it pays
really well like you're working out yeah
high salaries okay talk to her quite
like you have good conversations with
people and that's what I really love
about is that you're having
conversations with really professional
people that know about the passionate
about what they do you're equally as
passionate about helping them with
recruitment so I think yeah definitely
like anyone out there don't just kind of
take the first thing and go oh well this
is the technology or recruiting for
challenged
a little harder if you're brand new to
recruiting but I think you should
challenge the business a little bit if
you okay if you're doing the recruitment
coming they go to you right you need to
recruit this and you're like but hang on
a minute the technology says that we're
going this way and I'm reading about it
and I'm find and actually there are some
really good tech trends go and talk to
your manager and say actually I think we
need to be doing this yeah so ok so
start speaking to candidates yeah how
may it there could be so many different
types of job titles that you could go
for yeah how the father you identify
that so I I'm pretty much kind of like
sat down and just did research I was
rich on job serve I was putting in
cybersecurity I was looking at the
different levels of cybersecurity on
Google okay um just researching like I
don't I don't think necessarily people
realize how important research can be
happen at the market mapping out the
market researching it understanding the
different job titles and you know just
how important that can be to your market
and like what you're recruiting for like
there's no point just like I say
recruitment if you've never researched
that you know nothing about it
yeah actually go away sit down really do
some research look into it again you
don't have to know like everything like
people the other end mm be my thing
right how how because I think that's
what a lot of people worried about so
like how was it received by these people
and how did you approach these people
when talk talking about a technology
market you never done before so I think
like if you're really honest with people
and I kind of said this earlier I think
if you're really honest with candidates
and kind of say look maybe like you're
brand new to it started kind of say oh I
just wanted to know a little bit more
about this technology on your CV can you
tell me a little bit about it ask these
candidates like what's the next
technology trend for you like what you
seen on the market yeah and like I say
just just having those really kind of
open honest conversation with canvas I'd
do it now like if I see something I'm
not an expert on cybersecurity you know
I'm not a cyber security engineer I
don't I don't have that but like so I'm
always like asking the guys that oh
what's the latest thing what do you
think we should look out for like
trend-wise yeah and just being really
honest with them like these people like
no matter what tech market you recruit
and they know you are not a technical
person so don't kind of get hung up and
worried about it
they respect what you're doing is a job
and they know that you're not there to
be technical you're there to try and
like talk to about job you've got I like
it so so start with candidates yeah hand
conversations start off skin open
questions doing your research clearly
how did you get jobs on me
just everything like just non-stop kind
of it I think we're going to talk about
it is just that resilient piece really
like it just knowing that you know it
takes time to get clients on like I knew
from like back in like when I worked in
Fraser I knew that it sometimes can take
a year to get a client on I think one
that you long kills me so how long how
long did you give yourself what for to
like pull jobs like mate placements pull
jobs obviously I'm still doing it now
but like mentally but for people
listening cuz again I think this is the
thing right a lot of people can't get
their head above the war and thing like
when is this gonna change to lighten no
obviously you've got the added context
of working on cream for six years before
taking this leap who ever like in your
mind like how long did you give yourself
to be like right so if I haven't got
some success by X you like maybe I
should reconsider my strategy yes I gave
myself kind of three four months to kind
of get a deal with in that space yeah I
kind of said right considering it's
absolutely brand-new I know nothing
about it which I've managed to do but
Alan did tell you so that deal took me I
think it was two months and it was when
an existing client but yeah man existing
client she was a client that the company
already were but yeah brand-new Mary the
business you know under work with again
I had no real you know sort of security
knowledge so I was really pleased with
that and I think now what about the how
long that takes to set your your own
client and job and fill your own job
you've done that yet no not yet okay so
there you go that's doing it and I think
that's like that is a completely honest
thing starting a new market I think if
you've got if you're starting a new
market even if you've got experience
like I have don't be worried about
taking a little bit longer because it
does your your there's a lot of
recruitment companies out there that
have been doing it for a little bit
longer have you pulled jobs yeah I
pulled jobs we've got some we got some
really good clients a lot hopefully now
you sort of see that I said the
six-month mark is where you after
everything you're doing talking to
candidates managers and a Dan all this
data onto bullhorn that's when you then
now we're now story the rewards which is
exciting so how so how have you what so
again back to the resilience piece right
so I'm sure this is sort of the self
talking the things you looking in your
head so like how and what sort of things
are you measuring or being aware of on a
monthly basis to be like right Joe keep
doing we're getting closer at six-month
mark client I know is I'm building
momentum here like what sort of things
are you sort of making sure you're
gunning forward to be like right that
month be add that haven't made a place
of and haven't pulled the job yet but
I've done this you know I mean what yeah
so I think definitely for me and and
anyone kind of starting a market from
scratch the the key thing is that so I
always run it was on the way that I'd
recruit and I did recruit before it's
very candidate driven so having these
candidates that are on the database that
you've spoken to that are good good
people you know I've now got I think
it's like two hundred and fifty seven
people I think I've added since I've
been there that are really really good
cybersecurity InfoSec people yeah and
being again coming down to just be not
really like rigid and on exactly what
you do like don't don't stray away from
it kind of be right I'm only adding in
the best people you want to work with
the best candidates the salaries that
are kind of like higher level like the
you know the 60 k plus salaries because
they're the guys I want to work with
they're higher fees and then just kind
of knowing that doing things like you
know the managers added how many
contacts we getting into the database
how many BD calls are we doing you know
making sure that you you are on top of
like doing the sales days making sure
that we're doing that like I'm not right
this is the list of people I'm going to
call I'm going to really like I'm gonna
get this done I'm going to call these
people making sure that you're searching
for people's mobile numbers like
something you know if anyone out there
that hasn't heard of this yeah go onto
the job board to put a manager name in
he's met his old TV Marvin
little simple things that that mobile
number can be like really helpful to
your like BD yeah of course so yeah so
just definitely doing things like that
making sure you know who's interviewing
who the companies out there recruiting
and staying on top of it and you know
there's obviously thousands or a
companies out there that are recruiting
but stick to the ones that you know
using agencies yeah and just keep going
with it keep you know keep knowing that
if you keep doing it and you keep doing
the same the same things over and over
again it can get mundane but it will
work and eventually someone will come
back to you and you'll be like I can't
this happened yeah so happy like this
one client has come back to me and you
just kind of have that kind of almost
like a bit of relief that after all that
hard work and put in all that effort it
will come and it will happen but you
just got to stick to it yeah just gotta
stick to it yeah and how how have how
has as you burn out this market with the
clients I mean at this point it's you're
getting these people to sort of buy into
you and say look I will deliver this
like how have you pitched it to clients
that obviously you've now got some good
clients on turns with that you've done
yourself but like what was again I'm
thinking like some people might be
thinking right get it Joe definite speak
to candidates you can be a bit more
confident in that straight out the gate
but the client side why these people
gonna give me a chance if I've had I've
got no track record because that's what
you come along when you've got
experience right yeah you've got no
track record like you haven't made a
single placement with a pet thing so
you've got a religion I mean you've got
a common core you've got to know your
Worth and all that but like how how have
you sort of articulated there and
communicate it to clients you've ended
up signing that I've interests so I'll
probably use a bit of a cliche sentences
you've probably heard it before but the
older act as if okay I've done if you've
heard that yeah all the actors if like
where you want to be where you want to
be top of that it's pretty cliché in the
recruitment world and quite cheesy but
it actually works like okay if you go
into a call and you're like you know
what the I am I have a really good
recruiter I don't worry don't matter
about that you may not know the
technology but know that you're a really
good recruiter I know that the effort
and the time that you will put into
recruiting that job yeah and know that
what the work that you will do to help
that client fill that job going into
that cool without mindset is really
gonna help you like it's really gonna
give you that like I even found like
even like
for me like I stand up I like stand up
if I'm on a call of a clock I get that
like that confidence comes from I
standing up and just being able to kind
of like you know again like articulate
what you do you know being able to just
be confident and saying that and say no
they don't know that you're not the best
recruiter out there they don't know that
they have no idea that you're yeah that
you might just be the person that has
the best CV that can give them the best
service and that's kind of the mindset
you gotta move and I you know even now I
do it now I'm to the clients out there
and sorry 20 clients listening but I'm
the best I'm the best I'm the best
security recruit that they're talking to
and I believe that yeah and I really
have that belief for and if that belief
so when we say actors if yeah what will
be saying it's like always we go are we
saying act as if you've made a shitload
of placements in the sub security world
and this is why why not the reason why
I'm pushing back on that is I don't know
because it's sort of 2 2 cards here I
feel like you could play you could lock
which you've already spoken of as being
honest yeah right yeah so and it's come
up a lot in here when people start their
own recruitment business or even pretend
to start the new market where people
have literally said hi Joe look this is
where I'm at right now this is the
marketing building now this is why these
are the people that I've been speaking
to all got two hundred plus people on
the database right now but this is where
I'm at
give me a chance yeah so that's not an
option right and what a lot of people
share them here is that you'd be
surprised how many businesses will give
you a good chance when I help out and
but take you on that journey I'll be
popular journey yeah and then you've got
this act as if obviously you can be
wherever you want with that but I guess
that that I'm just saying that's one
push them a bit back I think I'm in yeah
definitely and I think like the the bit
around like oh you know being something
that's like I've started my journey I've
got this many candidates that's still
like an element of like I guess we come
back to like the self-worth Indian
people that you're still a good
recruiter right yeah and still and
that's absolutely fine to kind of go
into that conversation go look actually
yeah all right I'm four months from in
but actually the last four months I've
been building a market I've been talking
to the air I've been actually doing this
and like I know I'm talking about and I
can really help you I give me an
opportunity sort of thing
yeah that act as if piece I think yeah
it's not gonna work for every court
don't get me wrong
yeah not and I think like you know in
every call you've gotta like you have to
kind of mirror what the situation is you
know yeah Annie sure and some instances
yeah it's not gonna work some instances
it's gonna work you know when you're on
a meeting like with a client and it's
you've never recruited in that space
before you have to kind of act like you
are aware of what you're doing you have
to kind of give that and portray that
kind of conference I think it's gotta be
a balance than that okay okay I think I
know I think I think because like I
think or I guess from one tank from when
your scent is light but you strike me as
someone that wouldn't be like this but
like if you went into that meeting
acting as if you never feel all this I
guess what I'll guess I'm wanting to
just be clear on is there that as a new
same act as if light with an arrogance
that you know I mean it's like it's it's
it's acting as if that you're something
that completely believes in the work
that you are the value that you're gonna
you're gonna deliver on this but the
same time having the humility to answer
right questions and find out it's not
about acting as if and going there being
a being a dick it's about like kind of
actually like acting and going like look
I know that I'm new but here's what I'm
doing yeah confidence and going look
yeah I know my worth and I'm gonna give
you the best service and it's that kind
of like level that it is like doing it
wrong it's difficult when you're brand
new to a group yeah that's hard that's a
hard thing but it will like that when if
you can have that mindset of doing that
and having those conversations getting
new clients on with new terms is going
to be like a lot easier and you know I
understand nothing
yeah it just it's just been interesting
we're going back and forth there because
I think some people will definitely find
that hard yeah I mean yeah no I totally
get it but I think just sort of
underlying that there's definitely
nothing wrong with you being someone and
sort of aspiring and acting as if you
are you're gonna be the best person in
the market there's nothing wrong with
that at all
I think for me how I've approached my
own business and stuff like that for me
I've sort of probably used a bit of both
yeah personally in like that's that's
just how I yes but it's just interesting
yeah yeah there's different ways to do
nothing like different like different
personalities again yeah I'm gonna tweak
the ways in which like work for them and
I think that's only that's about finding
out what works for you always feel what
works for me might not actually work
someone else I think that's quite an
important thing to make
yeah there are gonna be things that you
do have different everyone's different
yeah there's gonna be things I do or
someone else does that I'm gonna but
then you tweak it that's also made like
I love the fact that you've really clean
really gonna your comfort zone back to
basics like consulting again yeah yeah
mo well hopefully on the cusp of closing
your own put in place deal yeah yeah you
market new sector okay mate so look
before we finish couple of questions on
resilience ya know the event coming up
right so um yeah so just to sort the
first one is like what what does
resilience and recruitment mean to you
yeah cool so I had a little I think
about this yeah Mike because I yeah you
only gave me there no I said yeah so I
think resilience for me like is um it's
um it's a multitude of different things
I don't think there's one thing that you
can pinpoint is someone that is
resilient yeah I think there's like a
lot of different elements that make
someone resilient as an individual and
uh like I said earlier I think even
things little things like being on time
being on time for work just shows that
you're your real willingness to do this
and your resilience to keep at this and
little things like that like can be a
massive difference in you as an
individual yeah I think there's
resilience can also like for me like
personally I believe that resilience can
be taught yeah
so if you've got a really good mentor
and someone that is telling you that
actually things do not always go well
yeah things in recruitment and in sales
in general typically will be going wrong
or not the way you want it to go but if
someone's actually kind of educating you
on that you're more likely to build up a
tolerance of like actually do you know
what I didn't do a deal but I'm gonna
keep going and I'm gonna keep trying
that and I'm gonna keep it giving it my
best shot because I want to be
successful so I think for me it's a
multitude of like different things of
like you know like I say like just
different elements that can make someone
a resilient a resilient individual yeah
nice now I'm happy with that I think for
you answered ok that's cool so before I
actually the final question mate yeah
what what are you excited about what's
gone on in your word that you wanna
shout about
so I'm excited I kind of I'm excited
about building a business that's what
I'm really excited about I'm excited
about from scratch I'm excited about the
direction that the business is going in
the trust that the directors have in me
as a person to be able to deliver the
trust that it doesn't happen overnight
even at my even my six years ago a
criminal experience yeah I know I can't
build a business within a few months or
do you know hundred grands worth of
deals in six months I just know that
that's not that's not where it is but
yeah really excited that the business is
definitely going in the right direction
you know we're trying to build something
we've just moved to like a nicer office
which is really cool like it's a bit
more like quirky vibe now like you know
we're really excited about so yeah and
you know moved in with my girlfriend
which a bit more personal no but now you
know paying bills and stuff and a big
change that me oh yeah she's actually
gonna be listening to this so I'm not
sure honestly I think a lot of people I
think back to sort of what you said
around you can obviously like when you
work for a big business like there's
pros and cons obviously but you you can
be comfortable like you could have
stayed and there's nothing wrong with it
but you could have stayed at AF and not
left there and that's fine but you
decided not to
you've got your comfort zone yeah fair
play Matt yeah I think there's like
there's so much like and I'm not trying
to say or anyone just like leave your
job but there is it like for people that
are maybe looking for work that
listening that want to know like what's
out there and you know like there is a
lot out there go and explore go and have
a little look don't be afraid to go and
try something that you've never done
before go to a company that kind of
trusts and believes in you and can see
that like you know see that kind of
passion in you to do recruitment and if
you really want to get into it go and
explore those smaller companies that
kind of maybe can trust you and you can
be part of something can kind of get
really you know get right out your
comfort zone and try something ever done
before
and just kind of like go with it and
that's kind of what I've done I've
really kind of just like know what work
some equipment for me and kind of over
the last kind of six years or so and
just trying it like I'm enjoying it it's
something so different it's kind of like
a new element to my life sauce yeah yeah
my select final question yeah you can
answer this with a phrase a sentence of
word whatever comes to mind if Joe could
communicate to you every single recruit
out there they'd listen they take on
your advice I'd implement it tomorrow
what do you got to say to the people
mate to the people don't worry about not
doing deals or get in like real hung up
on like recruitment and panicking don't
worry about if you're new to recruitment
even if you're like long in the tooth to
recruitment don't panic you know action
manager for help ask people around you
for help look for advice and just enjoy
recruitment and what it actually is you
know don't get like down about it you
know if you're going to work every day
like this is all for I hate it probably
not maybe not right for you but if you
are not really enjoying it and yeah just
just don't panic about it you know like
just enjoy the job from what it is this
for me [ __ ] amazing recruitments
brilliant say hey Joe it's been a
pleasure cool thank you very much
appreciate it